Hello. Hi.
I'm Dr. Shoukath Ansari,
an actor, performer,
and a full-time physician.
You may remember me
by my role in Netflix,
Master of None,
season one,
for which I was snubbed
for an Emmy.
And Master of None,
season number two;
again, I was snubbed.
My son, Aziz,
asked me to come here
to talk about a new stand-up
special coming in Netflix,
but something more important
I need to talk to you about:
Colon cancer.
Colon cancer is
number two killer in America.
We can prevent it
by doing screening colonoscopy.
Colonoscopy is an examination
of your large intestine.
You'll drink a gallon of
solution, clean you out,
and pass a rubber tube
all through the butthole,
examine the whole intestine.
Anybody about
45 should be screened
if black, or white, or even
brown, doesn't matter.
Get an appointment
for screening colonoscopy
and drop your pants.
That's all.
Bye-bye.
Did I do good?